on va rester dans les dans les archives
puisque on va parler des Archives
départementales qui viennent de
renforcer leur outil d'intégration de la
presse locale ancienne on le disait tout
à l'heure hein plus de 220000 pages sont
accessibles en ligne couvrant les années
1819 à 1969 romain Dugat est avec nous
en plateau pour en parler vous êtes le
chef du service au public des Archives
départementales des Yvelines pourquoi
avoir voulu ce nouveau module de
recherche alors il faut dire que c'était
quelque chose de très attendu par nos
internautes
la presse locale en fait elle est
numérisée depuis 2009
nous avions à l'époque déjà initié en
fait ce qu'on appelle l'OCR c'est à dire
la reconnaissance optique de caractères
qui permet de faire des recherches plein
texte à partir d'un mot clé de
rechercher toutes les occurrences dans
les pages numérisées et c'est vrai que
le désavantage d'être pionnier parfois
c'est que elle est montée de versions
ont rendu l'outil obsolète d'accord et
donc nous avons profité d'une montée de
versions de notre site de nouvelles
fonctionnalités pour reprendre ce
chantier et donc rehaussériser si j'ose
dire l'ensemble de des titres déjà
présents en ligne et permettre cette
fonctionnalité de recherche alors
comment ça fonctionne très concrètement
est-ce qu'on fait une recherche par mots
clés par date le titre de parution alors
on peut faire un peu tout ça d'accord
c'est à dire que on conserve 250 titres
de presse local ancienne comme vous
l'avez dit et parmi ces 250 titres sans
sont déjà une centaine sont déjà
numérisés et accessible en ligne
continuez à numériser les nouveaux les
nouveaux seront bénéficieront de cette
nouvelle
possibilité de recherche par le
paroscarisation et actuellement on peut
donc chercher soit sur un titre soit sur
une année soit sur une période soit sur
un mot clé c'est-à-dire que si vous
tapez le nom de votre ancêtre par
exemple et bien vous allez retrouver
toutes les occurrences dans tous les
titres de presse actuellement
disponibles oui très concrètement un
simple mot va nous permettre de
retrouver exactement les choses
puisqu'en fait l'ensemble si vous voulez
nous avons c'est comme si on avait passé
en revue l'ensemble des mots contenus
dans tous les des titres de presse qui
sont actuellement disponibles en ligne
et donc tous ces mots sont reconnus et
le simple fait de les taper dans le dans
le champ dédié à la recherche plein
texte va vous permettre de retrouver
tous les articles contenant ce mot par
zone géographique aussi c'est possible
exactement c'est à dire que les le
nouvel outil permet aussi une
cartographie des résultats c'est-à-dire
que les les parfois pour certains titres
on a vraiment des publications très
locales au niveau d'un arrondissement au
niveau d'une commune et donc vous pouvez
faire afficher les titres de presse par
la ville qui vous intéresse c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez sélectionner une ville
voir tous les titres de presse qui ont
été publiés sur cette ville donc voilà
on peut croiser bien sûr aussi les les
choses c'est à dire que vous pouvez
saisir un mot saisir une période
chronologique saisir un lieu
géographique et ça va vous sélectionner
au fur et à mesure ça va filtrer vos
résultats pour trouver l'occurrence la
plus précise que vous souhaitez comme
mixer tout ça pour arriver effectivement
à de bons résultats alors vous le disiez
ça concerne une centaine de titres la
période c'est 1819 à
1962 est-ce que s’est amené à évoluer
est-ce que il y a d'autres titres qui
pourraient se rajouter alors on conserve
que le jeudi 250 titres donc on continue
c'est à dire qu'en 2022 on a ajouté 25
nouveaux titres en ligne il y en a déjà
deux cette année qui qui sont prévus
donc on continue à numériser d'accord et
puis nous nous des partenariats avec des
communes cette année avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les années
précédentes avec Versailles avec des
associations
l'association historique de Rambouillet
qui détiennent des collections de titres
de presse on fait l'inventaire en fait
des collections que nous conservons
parfois il y a des lacunes dans les dans
les périodes très anciennes il nous
manque un numéro donc en conventionne
avec ces avec ses partenaires pour
numériser les titres qui nous manquent
et l'idée pour nous c'est d'avoir
vraiment une collection numérique de
référence on ne prend pas les bien sûr
les les originaux qui restent dans les
les fonds de nos partenaires mais ça va
permettre à terme d'avoir la collection
de références de presse local anciennes
sur l'ensemble du territoire de ce qui
était la ciné Oise précédemment et pas
simplement les Yvelines puisque ça
dépasse globalement le territoire actuel
des Yvelines et donc tout cela facilité
où vous disiez par des partenariats avec
différents organismes je sais qu'on a
fait tous les deux des études d'histoire
Michael et vous étiez déjà plongé dans
des archives pour des
exposés des mémoires peut-être après pas
forcément sur la presse locale donc je
trouve que c'est hyper intéressant et
juste une petite question est-ce que
vous allez faire ça peut-être à l'avenir
sur aussi des bon là c'est j'ai compris
que c'était sur une période
d'inventielle mais sur des vidéos aussi
ça serait possible ou pas on peut tout à
fait après c'est un travail qui est
différent puisque
c'est pas le même technique c'est le
même technologie de reconnaissance mais
tout à fait après Lina doit faire un
système sans doute d'indexation aussi
pour pour reconnaître tout ça TV 78
et certainement des choses à faire aussi
du côté des archives audiovisuels et le
but donc c'est de faciliter justement
l'accès à ses ressources aux Yvelines
noires au plus grand nombre tout à fait
ça permet
parce que jusqu'à présent la
numérisation simple ne permet que de
consulter comme si vous consultiez les
originaux c'est-à-dire qu'il fallait
tourner les images une à une comme vous
tourneriez les pages papier des journaux
là c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui cherche
un événement son ancêtre
un mot clé qui fait une recherche je ne
sais pas par exemple prenons parler du
sport tout à l'heure nous avons
travaillé justement avec les étudiants
de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour qu'il
nous recherche des archives sur
l'histoire du sport
à travers la presse forcément si vous
pouvez si vous pouvez indiquer le mot
vélo ou golf et que ça vous sort toutes
les occurrences dans tous les articles
ça facilite le travail que d'avoir un
dépouillement systématique alors si je
peux ajouter un petit mot sur les
nouveautés qui vont arriver puisque ça
c'est l'état actuel on est en train de
travailler justement aussi à des notices
par titre pour documenter à la fois qui
était le directeur faut savoir que
certains titres de presse à l'époque du
19e était parfois très éphémère c'était
souvent un outil de propagande qui
soutenait une candidature électorale et
donc c'est aussi intéressant de savoir
quel était le positionnement de tel
était le journal qui a été son
orientation politique donc on travaille
en fait à documenter tout ça quel était
le
l'éditeur le rédacteur en chef
l'orientation le courant politique d'un
journal pour par exemple permettre aussi
des recherches sur on veut travailler
sur la presse légitimiste savoir quels
étaient les orientations favorites les
sujets favoris d'un titre de presse et
bien on va pouvoir le faire avec ce
travail très intéressant
mais vous avez le droit d'aller dans la
petite question très rapide je voulais
juste savoir est-ce qu'il y a un fait
insolite qui vous a marqué dans dans ce
que vous avez pu voir il y a mille fins
insolites vous imaginez que à chaque
fois c'est la question piège quel est
l'archive les archives que vous
sélectionnerez parmi 32 km c'est c'est
impossible pour moi de choisir il y en a
beaucoup il y en a beaucoup que ce soit
dans le domaine sportif politique
culturel enfin chacun trouvera c'est
justement l'intérêt de cette ind exation
c'est que chacun pourra trouver le
l'événement la particularité singulière
qui qui le touche en tout cas pour ceux
que ça intéresse le site des archives à
retrouver bien sûr en bas de l'écran on
tape on va sur l'onglet rechercher et
puis presse locale ancienne si on veut
un peu plus d'informations merci Romain
d'être venu en parler en plateau je le
rappelle chef du service au public aux
archives départementales des y